so it's a new week and we are
essentially at the start of the 2020
election right now now
of course we've been figuring out who's
going to be the democratic nominee
people have been campaigning for a year
now uh
but what i mean is we are now just weeks
as i told you last week from the first
votes early voting and absentee voting
starting in in
at least three states in just over five
weeks so
we need to have a very precise plan for
the next
five weeks and of course for the three
months until the november election and
the plan
as much as being an offensive plan
against
donald trump in order to remove donald
trump the left needs a defensive plan as
well and i mean defense against
self-destructive elements of the left so
that we don't self-destruct and allow
donald trump to get another four years
in office
which would be i mean listen i don't
want to be hyperbolic i don't
even want to assign language to it right
now because it's not the point of this
story
but another four years of trump would be
very very bad let's put it that way
and one of the things that we have to be
very careful of right now
is for the left to avoid engaging in
fights that right now are irrelevant
and could potentially simply allow trump
to get another four years
my advice for the left first of all my
advice is
for the left and not for the right
because i'm on the left the right is
making all sorts of
mistakes i hope they continue to make
mistakes and we should let them make
mistakes this is not about giving the
right advice
this is about giving the left advice but
at the same time
we should understand how certain fights
that are right now irrelevant don't need
to be
put aside forever we just need to be
thinking
carefully about what we're doing and
that's where i want to go first
this is not a disclaimer but it is a
clarification
this is not about compromising
progressive policy or values
this is just realizing we have three
months left
we have to come together these three
months are the last thing we have to
remove donald trump and we have to put
policy differences within the left
that are currently irrelevant aside
because if trump wins our chances
of getting anything done are zero in
other words the
intra-left debates if trump wins will be
irrelevant for four more years
because either way we're not getting
anything done with donald trump in the
white house again
if joe biden wins then we go right
back to these disagreements within the
left because the point is
what do we want to push joe biden to do
what can we push joe biden to do
from the left and if democrats were able
to take the senate in november
which is looking more likely now than it
was a month ago i'll talk about that
later
it becomes an even more important
discussion now what i'm specifically
looking to hear
are some of the different wings of the
left where there are disagreements
and what i want is for everybody to
understand
that we don't lose anything by
postponing these disagreements for three
months
and we do ourselves a lot of good
without harming the movement now i'll
give you some examples to make this
really clear i don't want this to just
remain some vague thing
socialism versus social democracy okay
this has become a very important
popular relevant heated debate
on the left lately right now that debate
does nothing for us
it actually does nothing for us in two
different ways number one
whether you want socialism or social
democracy
the next step is social democracy from
where we are today there's no way the
united states is going to be a socialist
country anytime soon
when trump warns the marxists are taking
over
that's not true uh when the the right
warns the u.s could become socialist if
biden wins
that's not true and when the socialist
left says
we could have a socialist revolution and
be a socialist country
none of those things are happening
anytime soon and so the point is
if you're a socialist which i happen not
to be
you are going to have to come through
social democracy to get to socialism
that's the reality
with biden we have the opportunity to
get some policy done that is socially
democratic
if you look at biden's ideas on health
care taxation climate change clean
energy
they're not exactly what i want and i'll
address that later
but they're closer to the direction that
both
social democrats and socialists want to
go from where we are
today so we're not going to finish that
fight in the next three months
we're just not let's get trump out and
then let's start pushing biden in the
direction we all agree he
needs to go at some point in the future
if we succeed
socialism versus social democracy will
be relevant to policy
it's not the next step it's not
happening in the next three months so
why are we going to argue about
that right now when we're trying to
remove donald trump
just some other little examples here's
one that i thought of just looking at my
twitter this morning
there's this journalist mehdi hassan and
we follow each other on twitter
i've read it retweeted some of his work
that i think is great
he's retweeted some of our stuff we're
in agreement about many many things
we happen to disagree mattie and i about
bds with respect to israel boycott
divestment sanctions movement
i believe that the movement is
counterproductive i don't think it will
lead to the kind of change
i want to see medi-hasan supports bds
great it's a disagreement it's a
completely irrelevant one for the next
three months
because we have a president i think both
media and i would agree
we have a president right now who's in
bed with the worst of the israeli right
in his support of benjamin netanyahu
and has the worst instincts period when
it comes to the israeli-palestinian
conflict
so we're both against benjamin netanyahu
we're both against donald trump
trump must be removed so why would we
argue about bds
for the next three months rather than
focusing on removing donald trump
another example which is maybe more
relevant to you in the immediate
single-payer healthcare trump is not for
single-payer
neither is joe biden what joe biden is
proposing
is better than what donald trump is
proposing and most democrats in the
senate
don't even support single-payer health
care right now so
for the next three months why would we
make the dividing line
does biden support single-payer or not
it makes no sense either biden or trump
are going to be inaugurated
on january 20th health care will improve
if biden gets his way we can push him to
improve it even more
hopefully and with trump we get nothing
we get fewer people covered if trump
gets his way so what are we doing
now for people who are going to react
very negatively to what i'm saying
and they'll write to me and they'll say
david you're only saying this because
you're not a socialist and you are a
democratic party shill or whatever
argument you're going to make
you're missing exactly the point that
i'm making whether or not i'm a
democratic chill and
by the way i'm not i'm not even a
democrat has no bearing whatsoever
on the left having opportunity with joe
biden
and none with donald trump that's it and
it's particularly important
right now not to operate for the next
three months
in a way that will serve to divide the
left
and give donald trump in the right an
opportunity to be elected for another
four years
partially by fomenting this division on
the left which is exactly what they want
to do
on january 21st if joe biden is
inaugurated on january 20th on january
21st
we have the ball back as i like to say
and we immediately go back to these
important discussions we immediately go
back on january 21st
to seeing the republicans in the lincoln
project this republican group trying to
remove trump
as soon as biden's inaugurated they're
no longer on our side i
imagine they immediately go back to
advocating for their you know so-called
small government conservative values or
whatever
these are all discussions you know about
health care or whatever topic
we go right back to those discussions
and in fact
if we do get the ball back uh
which i would that's how i've been
analogizing
removing trump and electing joe biden
once we get the ball back
we then have to try to put some points
on the board and that means
arguing about the right plays to call
and having these policy debates but at
this point
it's july 27th if we miss the forest for
the trees we're not just doing the
united states a disservice
we're doing the world a disservice given
the level of destruction that donald
trump has reigned upon this country
over the last three and a half years so
this is not
shut up and get in line with democratic
party centrism and cronyism that's not
what this is about
this is about we get nothing if donald
trump gets re-elected
the world will hate us even more it will
ruin our relationships with allies even
more
it will put us even further behind on
climate change irreparably so
versus we get trump out
biden goes in hopefully with a
reasonable reasonable vice president i
which we
should know soon i want to know who the
cabinet will be
we want to keep looking at the policy
and we have an opportunity
if joe biden gets elected now there will
be a contingent of my audience
that will disagree on principle with
what i'm saying
because they are in the camp of you've
got to burn it all down to build it back
up
and these are some of the same folks who
said if it's not going to be bernie in
2016 i don't care if it's trump because
it'll accelerate the destruction of the
country well
we're really no closer to any kind of
socialist revolution
as a result of four years of trump but
we are destroying the planet
we're in the middle of arguably one of
the worst five global responses to this
pandemic coronavirus pandemic
which has subsequently led to an even
worse economic disaster than was
necessary
it it's failed that that approach has
failed and go back and check out my
clips where i point out
the progress in the modern political era
has been incremental progress
by getting better people in getting
better people on the supreme court
and moving things in the right direction
so let's come together
let's do the right thing and i promise
you in three months
we can get right back to the same
divisive debates
if that's what you want to do hopefully
in a more productive way
with the experience and hindsight
of seeing what we experienced during the
donald trump
presidency if we get another four years
of trump who knows
what's next but it's not good so let's
come together on this issue
this is not a long time you know for
people desperate to talk about
uh a a socialist revolution
to knock out neo-liberalism and you know
that wing
of of my audience three months is not a
long time let's just put that energy to
get out the vote
and removing donald trump it's just
three months okay it's gonna go look
we've been in quarantine for five months
it's gone by like that because every day
looks very very similar
these three months will go by quickly
even during the transition we can get
back to these debates if that what
that's what you want
let's do it let's come together for the
next three months let me know where you
disagree with me
i'm on twitter at deepakman and remember
you can get the daily
audio podcast from the david pakman show
every single day right around 3 p.m
eastern noon pacific
on any of your favorite or least
despised podcasting apps whether that's
google play podcasts or spotify pandora
iheartradio itunes etc etc get the daily
audio podcast let me know what you think
about avoiding these
self-destructive and presently
irrelevant debates on twitter
deepakman and i will be back with much
more
just moments from now if you love
feeding your intellectual curiosity but
you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can
get through in just 15 minutes and you
get all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video